we think of vulnerability as a dark
emotion we think of it as the core of
fear and shame and grief and
disappointment uncertainty things that
we do not want to feel right I call
perfectionism the 20-ton shield we
carried around thinking it's gonna
protect us from being hurt yeah but it
protects us from being seen but how many
of you were raised in families were you
encouraged to get curious about your
emotions and talk about them and explore
them right versus how many of you were
raised in families where you were taught
hey suck it up yep
push through and get it done so I hope
your journey today we're gonna learn
from best-selling often pretty Brown and
my take on your top ten success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always as you're
watching if you hear something that
resonates with you please leave it then
it comes below the quotes around it so
other people can be inspired might win a
prize as well and also when you write it
down as much likely to stick for
yourself as well
enjoy
and so my story is that I am a
researcher and I never thought I would
have a big public career and so I did a
TED talk that went very viral and in the
wake of that I was kind of everywhere
for a couple of months on every cnn.com
NPR it was everywhere and something I
wasn't used to and the marching orders
from my therapist and my husband were do
not read the comments online so I read
all the comments online it's a one
morning I woke up and there were two or
three new articles out and I started
reading the comments and they were
devastating they weren't about my work
they were about me they were super
personal and they were the things that
created people play in their mind and
then give up doing what they really want
to do like if I asked every single one
of you you would try what would you try
if you knew people would never say this
about you what would that what would
this be
it would those were the comments that
morning
of course she embraces imperfection what
choice does she have look what look at
how she looks I feel sorry for her kids
less research more Botox just mean
personal attacks the things that really
up until that moment had inspired me to
stay very small in my life in my career
just so I could avoid those things so
that morning Stephen the kids leave I
stay home I get on the couch and I watch
eight hours of Downton Abbey
[Music]
and when it's over I don't want to turn
off Downton Abbey because I then because
you did minute you turn off Downton
Abbey then it's like soccer practice and
dinner and back to the mean people and
maybe should I get motox and maybe you
know maybe if I stand still when I talk
so I get my laptop and I do a search for
who was president in the United States
during the Downton Abbey era have you
ever done that like you you're numbing
with TV or movie and so when it's over
you just like stay in that space by like
learning more about the actors and
what's going on I've been doing this
long enough to know this is like you're
laughing with me not so I put it in and
Theodore Roosevelt comes up and a quote
comes up and I read it and this is what
it says it's a quote from a speech that
he gave in the early nineteen hundred's
at the Sorbonne and a lot of people
called them in the arena speech and this
is the passage that changed changes my
life it's not the critic who counts it's
not the man who points out how the
strong man stumbles or where the doer of
Deeds could have done it better the
credit belongs to the person who's
actually in the arena whose face is
marred with blood and sweat and dust who
at the best in the end knows the triumph
of high achievement and who at worst if
he fails he fails daring greatly so the
moment that I read that I closed my
laptop and this is what shifted in me
three huge things first I've spent the
last 12 years studying vulnerability and
that quote was everything I know about
vulnerability it is not about winning
it's not about losing it's about showing
up and being seen the second thing this
is who I want to be I want to create I
want to make things that didn't exist
before I touch them I want to show up
and be seen in my work and in my life
and if you're going to show up and be
seen there is only one guarantee and
that is
we'll get your ass kicked that is the
guarantee that's the only certainty you
have if you're gonna go in the arena and
spend any time in there whatsoever
especially if you've committed to
creating in your life you will get your
ass kicked so you have to decide at that
moment I think for all of us if courage
is a value that we hold this is a
consequence you can't avoid it
the third thing which really set me free
and I think Steve my husband would argue
has made me somewhat dangerous it's kind
of a new philosophy about criticism
which is this if you're not in the arena
also getting your ass kicked I'm not
interested in your feedback what does it
mean to be a wholehearted person you
have actually you know a list of ten
different qualities that wholehearted
people have in common
and so cultivating authenticity letting
go of what people think that's the first
one let's talk about that it's so hard I
thought doing this research I thought
going into it there were authentic
people and inauthentic people who I had
I did not find any evidence of that at
all what I found is authenticity to
practice and you choose it every day
sometimes every hour of every day and
it's a practice it's not I just wake up
in hamath entik it's that when you walk
into a meeting you have to make the
choice am I going to show up and let
myself be seen am I gonna if I could
raise my hands like wow y'all look super
excited I don't know what in the hell
you're talking about you know that's a
choice yes uh-huh
right yeah and what tend to be make that
authentic choice yeah let go of the
faker faker ooh I said yeah I call it
the faker roof but you know what I have
found I mean I consider myself to be an
authentic person but when I am
inauthentic is when I've allowed myself
to be around people who were not and
then I have to fake it to be with them
it's contagious yes so they're faking it
yeah then and you know you're in that
situation when you do that uh-huh that
kind of haha you're laughing at jokes
that aren't funny
you're pretending to be comfortable when
you're not and lose your own
authenticity yeah I do
one of the most shocking findings of my
work was the idea that the most
compassionate people I have interviewed
over the last 13 years were also be
absolutely most bound reading because
the most boundaries they I'll give you a
great definition of the definition of
boundary that I use in the book boundary
is simply what's okay and what's not
okay what I think we do is we don't set
boundaries we let people do things that
are not okay or get away with behaviors
that are not okay then we'll just
resentful and hateful mean I'd rather be
loving and generous and very
straightforward with what's okay and
what's not okay so my question is big
b.i.g what boundaries need to be in
place for me to stay in my integrity and
make the most generous assumptions about
you but generosity can't exist without
boundaries and we are not comfortable
setting boundaries because we care more
about what people will think and we
don't want to disappoint anyone we want
everyone to like us and boundaries are
not easy but I think they're the key to
self-love and I think they're the key to
treating others with loving kindness
sustained
you can't nothing is sustainable without
boundaries what I found you know twelve
years of research eleven thousand pieces
of data I had I did not interview and
all that time a person who would
describe themselves as joyful or
describe their lives as joyous who did
not actively practice gratitude and for
me it was very counterintuitive because
I kind of went into the research
thinking that the relationship between
joy and gratitude was if you're joyful
then you should be grateful but it
wasn't that way at all it was really
that practicing gratitude invites joy
into our lives and when I say practice I
think this is this is the part that
really changed my life it changed my
family and the way we live every day
when I say practice gratitude I don't
mean kind of like the attitude of
gratitude or feeling grateful
I mean practicing
gratitude these folks shared in common a
tangible gratitude practice they either
kept gratitude journals some of them did
interesting things like at 1 2 3 4 like
at 12:30 for every day they said
something out loud that they were
grateful for they one of the things that
we do like we say grace at dinner and so
now after grace we go around and
everyone in my family says something
they're grateful for I mean including
what's interesting is when we first
started I have a first grader at first
grade sight in Charlie and 8th grade
daughter Ellen and at first I thought
and we've been doing for a couple years
now like they're like oh god mom and if
there was a little like this is you know
are you experimenting on us it's a
little bit of that but now what's
interesting even after we did it for
like a couple of weeks that on those
crazy busy nights where we're trying to
like get to soccer and piano and
homework and Steve and I are just like
resuit we say a quick prayer we start
eating my kids are like whoa what are
you grateful for and it's been
extraordinary because not only
absolutely does it invite more joy into
our house it also is such a soulful
window into what's going on in my kids
lives you know so there's some days when
my eighth grader I'll be like I'm joyful
that there's a huge thick wall between
my room and my brother's room you know
something he's very you know honest but
there other day she'll say you know she
had a friend whose mother recently died
and she said you know for a month she
would say I'm just so grateful that you
all are healthy right now you know and
so not only did it make us all more
aware of what we had and more willing to
slow down and really be thankful for the
joyful moments we had but it let me know
where she was emotionally in her life
you know and my side is always you know
I'm grateful for bugs I'm grateful for
frogs but sometimes he'll say you know
I'm grateful that you picked me up early
or you know I'm grateful that I finally
understand adjectives you know so it's
there's a great quote that says it's not
granted it's not joy that makes us
grateful it's gratitude that makes us
joyful and it's by a Jesuit brother a
Jesuit priest
and I guess I was just amazed to find
that bubble up so strongly in the
research its life-changing we think
about vulnerability as a dark emotion
you know there are a lot of feet people
who talk about litem you know positive
emotions negative emotions dark emotions
light emotions we think of vulnerability
as a dark emotion we think of it as the
core of fear and shame and grief and
disappointment uncertainty things that
we do not want to feel right things that
I don't want to be vulnerable because
that means I'm afraid that means I'm
uncertain that means I'm at risk I'm
exposed I'm I'm in grief so what we do
is we armor up and we say I do not want
to slip into these dark emotions I will
not let myself be vulnerable but here's
what I learn from the research and
certainly put into motion in my own life
that was the most life-changing is that
vulnerability is the center of difficult
emotion but it's also the birthplace of
every positive emotion that we need in
our lives
love belonging joy empathy how many of
you would agree that we're in a serious
empathy deficit in our culture today
totally right no vulnerability no
empathy in a culture where people are
afraid to be vulnerable you can't have
empathy here empathy is not a default
response if you share something with me
that's difficult in order for me to be
truly empathic I have to step into what
you're feeling and that's vulnerable so
there can be no empathy without
vulnerability why do you think in that
example that I used while ago daughter
comes home and says you know tears no
one sat with me at lunch today they made
fun of what I was wearing
so-and-so won't talk to me they poured
my books out of my locker
and the response back is I told you I
bought you all those cute jeans why
aren't you wearing those jeans and pull
your hair back
is that an empathic response no it's a
shaming response could that was shaming
response be if it could get a mother who
absolutely adores her child respond with
that shaming response
please say yes don't kid yourself I mean
come on if you've got a if you're a
parent sitting in here then you sure as
hell know the answer to that is yes but
why why did that happen what where was
the access to vulnerability where was I
mean where was empathy you can't access
empathy if you're not willing to be
vulnerable so if my daughter comes home
and tells that to me guess what I have
to do I have to reactivate that sweaty
palms seventh grader who lives inside me
and I have to go oh god that's so hard
I'm so sorry
that's happened to me that's happened to
me when I was in middle school and it's
happened to me last week let's talk
about it but you can't get there without
vulnerability you can't fake empathy
innovation and creativity born of
vulnerability this is my favorite part I
talked about this and then I did another
TED talk this year at Lynn Long Beach
and I told the story that during 2011
and even this year after the big TEDx
Houston talk went viral then the big
calls came from fortune 500 companies oh
my god we loved your TED talk it was
great please come talk to all of our
senior leaders and just like okay what
do you talk about like we don't care
just to come and talk to us just if you
could exhale shame and vulnerability
talk every single conversation
barring maybe 10% like what do you mean
well we well you know you're you know
you're funny
you have this great research I think
there's a real fit with what we do we
just we don't really do you know that
kind of stuff around here so you if you
could not mention vulnerability and
shame so just for fun for grins I would
say okay so what would you like me to
talk about yeah fourth-quarter earnings
like freaking don't even balance my
checkbook like I'm not going to talk
about that so what do you what do we
want what do you let me talk about well
the big issue creativity and innovation
mmm and change we're going through a lot
of change like okay so vulnerability is
the birthplace of creativity innovation
change and the reason that crisis is
happening is because you're not talking
about vulnerability imagine creativity
and innovation without vulnerability I'm
asking you for a work product that has
never been made before that's completely
innovative I need you to be creative and
then as you percent it to a group of
people who are going to happen I think
it's stupid and not understand it know
vulnerability their perfectionism what
emerged for me in the data was that
perfectionism is not about striving for
excellence or healthy striving which
yeah I'm for yeah it's a cognitive
behavioral process a way of thinking and
feeling that says this if I look perfect
do it perfect work perfect and live
perfect I can avoid or minimize shame
blame and judge haha you know what I
thought when it was reading this I had
another aha AHA
to people this was my other AHA that
perfectionism I never gotten this before
tolerate this that perfectionism is the
ultimate fear that the people who are
walking around as perfectionist who have
to have everything so yeah that they are
ultimately afraid that the world is
see them for who they really are and
they won't measure up there's no
question that's that's what it that's
great right that's exactly what it is
okay it's fear because it's very
different than trying to be excellent
and hard and doing your best yeah yeah
and so I call perfectionism the 20-ton
shield we carried around thinking it's
gonna protect us from being hurt yeah
but it protects us from being seen let
me tell you this real story this just
happened I spoke at HubSpot last week
okay
13,000 people in this Lawson Convention
Center it's like 10 minutes before I go
on and I'm making it I look at Twitter
and I'm this person since this tweet out
that says why is Brunei at HubSpot why
is at brené Brown at HubSpot 2015 and he
just tweeted like love seth godin love
amy schumer all these people but why is
Brene brown and i'm like oh my god
why am i at HubSpot what am i doing here
and then I'm like I start sweating and
it's like anyway it's a convention
center it's like bucha should give
ladies you know I'm like oh my god what
am i doing and I'm the opening keynote
I'm like and then he tweets it again and
I'm like oh my god
and so like these are marketing people I
don't know anything so I start googling
in my phone marketing terms 2015 and the
first time that comes up is
incentivizing like I've got to work that
I've got to work the word incentivize
into this this keynote I'm like what
does that mean exactly I don't know but
I'm gonna say we're gonna incentivize
I'm like what is happening and I have a
total crisis of confidence like because
you know shame drives to tapes not good
enough and who do you think you are and
like Who am I right stops terrible and
so then all of a sudden I'm like who is
it because what happens when you get
back to into a corner my brain is making
up the story you don't belong here I'm
like that story's not gonna work cause
I'm going on in five seconds like so I'm
like okay
the best-case scenario attack attack
attack this guy maybe attack him from
the stage maybe you said as my opening
maybe say like John Doe asked what I'm
doing here well let me tell y'all you
know and then I click on the tweet to
figure out what his name is and I
accidentally hit the link in his tweet
and it goes to this page that says what
does brené Brown doing your HubSpot
she's talking about vulnerability and
that's so
important here's her TED talk here her
book could you imagine if I would have
got out there and been like a crate
totally no and that's a true story
it just happened because what happens is
when something hard happens and we're
captured by something difficult our
emotions get their first crack at making
sense of something bad look a hard
phonecall a disagreement at work we
think that we're rational beings we
think that cognition is going to carry
us through and make sense of it but it
doesn't you know emotions driving
thought and behavior are not even in the
front seat riding shotgun they're not
even the back seat thought and behavior
and the trunk going hey and emotions
driving so the first thing we do is we
tell ourselves a story that reduces
ambiguity about what happened so oh I'm
not supposed to be here I'm not good
enough to be here men and women who have
the greatest capacity for rising strong
in the moment something happens they
hack into that neurobiological process
of making up a story they stop and say
wait a minute what's actually going on
here what is what am I feeling what do I
know for sure because what is you know
what is a story there's a name in the
research for a story that has one or two
limited data points and we fill in the
rest with fear Wow it's called a
conspiracy a conspiracy is a story with
limited data points so here's what I
know I know a guy sent a tweet I know
I'm getting ready to talk that's all I
know so now that I'm ready to ruin his
career and use him as a whipping person
you know as I stalk what is going on the
first step of rising strong is recognize
you've been snagged by emotion and get
curious about it that's it but how many
of you were raised in families were you
encouraged to get curious about your
emotions and talk about them and explore
them right versus how many of you were
raised in families where you were taught
hey suck it up yep push through and get
it done so the first thing is really
reckoning with emotion what am I feeling
and when and what do I need to know more
about that is a heat and so that thing
that you say like it just is something
that someone knows something that I
don't know do they have information I
don't have
that's a huge part of the reckoning we
just don't do it so in that minute in
the backstage when I was happy on my
phone I could have just said
whoa burn a your like heart is racing
your your your teeth are clenched and
you're going in for the kill here what
do you know about this yeah nothing you
know nothing and what if you do
everything who cares it gives a [ __ ]
yeah you know there are 13,000 people
you're gonna spend an hour targeting one
guy you don't know
a shame is far more likely to cause
destructive behaviors than it is to cure
it what we know is that shame is highly
correlated with addiction violence
aggression bullying it's not helpful to
be ashamed for this reason and I think
this is really a core thing that we need
to get our heads and hearts around as a
culture shame corrodes the part of us
that believes we can change so to change
someone into changing is like saying to
them you are horrible and worthless and
you're not capable of change get better
I have interviewed over 600 men and
women now across the country about shame
and across the interviews men and women
with high levels of resilience to shame
share four things in common the first is
they physically recognize when they're
in shame and they know what triggered it
so let's say something happens at work I
make a mistake or something happens and
that warm wash comes over me you know
that feeling yeah if I can physically
say oh my god this is shame I'm in shame
it's very helpful because we are not fit
for human consumption when we're in
shame we need to pull away and get re
grounded take some deep breaths and
figure out how to respond one of the
things that make shame worse is normally
when we're in it we act out for example
the mother that I interviewed she fills
her car up she goes into the gas station
she goes to pay her credit cards
declined the man shames her in front of
the other patrons makes her leave her I
think her wedding band and her wallet
and lead with just an ATM card so she's
filled with shame she gets in the car
she slams the door when she slams the
door at wakes up
year old toddler who's in the backseat
who starts screaming what happens next
she starts screaming back shut up shut
up so now she's in the shame of having
this credit card declined being
belittled in front of people and now
having to deal with the you know the
struggle of on the horrible mom and why
am I taking this out of my child so men
and women with high levels of resilience
recognize physically when they're in
shame and what triggered it okay
then they practice critical awareness
how realistic are the expectations and
messages that we put on ourselves
through that others put on us that tell
us who we're supposed to be the third
thing is men and women with high levels
of resilience reach out we've got to
share our story so they talk about it
they talk about it you know we breathe
through it we recognize we're in it and
then we call and say hey Patricia it's
me you're not gonna believe what
happened can you listen it's it's hard
and then we speak shame you know it's I
try to explain to people the importance
of using the word shame and this is not
just laypeople this is mental health
professionals you know we've got to use
the word it's different if I were to
call you into Oh Patricia it's Bray I'm
so embarrassed that would be one thing
right but if I were to call you and say
Patricia it's Brennan I'm really
struggling with some shame that's
different it's a different conversation
right shame cannot hold on when we name
it right so it's not just you know an
academic pet peeve I want everybody to
get the semantics correct men and women
with high levels of shame resilience use
the word and talk about the emotion I
think there's like a thin film of terror
wrapped around us and so if it's not I'm
not safe enough I'm not secure enough
it's I'm not liked enough I'm not
promoted enough I'm not loved enough I
just have another have enough I am not
enough at the very bottom yeah I'm not
enough yeah well that's big big bag bag
bag bag somebody rings some bells we
need some bells to ring on this show but
that's it and so guess what the number
one casualty is of a scarcity culture
what vulnerability we shut down we shut
down cuz I'm not gonna let you know now
because I'm not
right yeah and the thing is that people
like oh well we lose a little
vulnerability but vulnerability is not
just about fear and grief and
disappointment it's the birthplace of
everything we're hungry for creativity
joy creativity faith yeah innovation and
all of that yes and the whole thing is
there is no innovation and creativity
without failure period so you got to be
open enough to take the risk to fail
yeah what I have found in my life and
what I've found in my research which
fueled what I did in my life is that the
people who have the most courage who are
willing to show them be the most
vulnerable are the ones who are very
clear about who the critics are the ones
who reserved seats for them and say I
hear you I get it I know where the
messaging is coming from I'm not I'm not
in I'm not buying it anymore so to get
very clear the last thing which I think
is the hardest is this one of these
seats needs to be reserved for you one
of these seats needs to be reserved for
me I need when we look up and we're
putting an idea our piece of art our
design forward who do you think the
biggest critic in the arena normally is
yourself
and so definitely me like I have never
watched either of those TED Talks
because it's not in service of the work
for me
and I try to do things are only in
service of my work because what would
what would it serve for me to watch it I
would sit there and go oh my god suck in
your stomach oh my god that's not what
you were gonna say you know we're so
self-critical and one of the things that
I think happens and I think this happens
a lot it happens in different
professions but I think I see it a lot
with creatives is there is an ideal of
what you're supposed to be and what a
lot of us end up doing is we orphan the
parts
our selves that don't fit what that
ideal is supposed to be and what it
leaves when we orphan all those parts of
us is it just leaves the critic and so
reserved in this seat is this where we
came from how we started our families
that's me the oldest of course the Lost
years the years where I was so lost and
confused and hurt and disillusioned that
I thought the only path to freedom was a
flock of seagulls haircut the higher the
hair the closer to God we say in Texas
the people who love us the moments that
make us who we are and in that chair
should be this person the person who
believes in what we're doing and why
we're doing it and the person who says
yeah it's so scary to show up it feels
dangerous to be seen it's terrifying
but it is not as scary dangerous or
terrifying as getting to the end of our
lives and thinking what if I would have
shown up what would have been different
thank you guys sorry I can I hope you
enjoy they cast her vote on who you want
to see in the next top 10 check out the
link in the description and go vote for
the person that you want me to profile
next I also love to know which clip
resonated the most with you what lesson
even obtained this video and immediately
apply to even life or to business
somehow leave it down in the comments
below
I'm really curious to find out what you
have to say I also want to give a quick
shirt to the seal Keith the Torah thank
you so much the seal for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and
posting the picture on Instagram I
really really really appreciate you
support and I'm so glad that you enjoyed
it thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love
we numb vulnerability when we're waiting
for the call when we're trying to think
about if we're gonna you know it was
funny I guess Wednesday I sent something
out on Twitter on Twitter and on
Facebook that says what how would you
define vulnerability what makes you feel
vulnerable and within an hour and a half
I had 150 responses because I wanted to
know you know what what's out there
having to ask my husband for help
because I'm sick and we're newly married
initiating sex with my husband
initiating sex with my wife being turned
down asking someone out waiting for the
doctor to call back getting laid off
laying off people this is the world we
live in we live in a vulnerable world
and one of the ways we deal with it is
we numb vulnerability and I think
there's evidence and it's not the only
reason this evidence exists but I think
that there it's a huge cause we are the
most in debt obese addicted and
medicated adult cohort in US history the
problem is why the problem is and I
learned this from the research that you
cannot selectively numb emotion you
can't say here's the bad stuff here's
vulnerability here's grief here's Shane
here's fear here's disappointment I
don't want to feel these I'm going to
have a couple of beers and a Banana Nut
muffin
I don't want to feel these and I know
that today I know that's knowing
laughter I hack into your lives for a
living I know that's God
you can't numb those hard feelings
without numbing the other affects our
emotions you cannot selectively numb so
when we numb those we numb joy we numb
gratitude we numb happiness and then we
are miserable and we are looking for
purpose and meaning and then we feel
vulnerable so then we have a couple of
beers in a Banana Nut muffin and it
becomes this dangerous cycle one of the
things that I think that we need to
think about is why in how we numb and it
doesn't just have to be addiction the
other thing we do is we make everything
that's uncertain certain religion has
gone from a belief in faith and mystery
to certainty I'm right you're wrong shut
up that's it just certain the more
afraid we are the more vulnerable we are
the more afraid we are this is what
politics looks like today there's no
discourse anymore there's no
conversation
there's just blame you know what blame
you know how blame is described in the
research a way to discharge pain and
discomfort we perfect now let me check
if there's anyone who wants their life
to look like this it would be me but it
doesn't work because what we do is we
take fat from our butts and put it in
our cheeks
which does it which Jess I hope in a
hundred years people will look back and
go and we perfect most dangerously our
children let me tell you what we think
about let me thank you very quickly
about children they're hardwired for
struggle when they get here when you
sold those perfect little babies in your
hand our job is not to say look at them
look at her she's perfect my job is just
to keep her perfect make sure she makes
the tennis team by fifth grade and Yale
by seventh grade our job that's on our
job our job is to look and say you know
what you're imperfect and you're wired
for struggle but you are worthy of love
and belonging that's our job
show me a generation of kids raised like
that and we'll end the problems I think
that we see today we pretend that what
we do doesn't have an effect on people
we do that in our personal lives we do
that corporate whether it's a bailout an
oil spill a recall we pretend like what
we're doing does it have a huge impact
on other people yeah I would say to
companies something this is not our
first rodeo people we just need you to
be authentic and real and say we're
sorry we'll fix it but there's another
way and I'll leave you with this this is
what I have found to let ourselves be
seen deeply seen vulnerably seem to love
with our whole hearts even though
there's no guarantee and that's really
hard and I can tell you as a parent
that's excruciating ly difficult to
practice gratitude and joy in those
moments of kind of terror when we're
wondering can I love you this much can I
believe in this as passionately can I be
this fierce about this just to be able
to stop and instead of catastrophizing
what might happen to say I'm just so
grateful because to feel this vulnerable
means I'm alive and the last which I
think is probably the most important
is to believe that we're enough because
when we work from a place I believe that
says I'm enough then we stop screaming
and start listening
we're kinder and gentler to the people
around us and we're kinda and gentler to
ourselves that's all I have